so we're given a P of X it's a third
degree polynomial and they say plot all
the zeros or the x-intercepts of the
polynomial in the interactive graph and
there is why they say interactive graph
this is a screenshot from the exercise
on Khan Academy where you could click
and place the zeroes but the key here is
let's figure out what X values make P of
X equal to zero those are the zeros and
then we can plot them so pause this
video and see if you can figure that out
so the key here is to try to factor this
expression right over here this third
degree expression because really we're
trying to solve the X's for which five X
to the third plus five x squared minus
30x is equal to zero and the way we do
that is by factoring this left hand
expression so the first thing I always
look for is a common factor across all
of the terms it looks like all the terms
are divisible by five X so let's factor
out a 5 X so this is going to be 5x
times if we take a 5 X out of 5 X to the
third we're left with an x squared we
take out a 5 X out of 5 x squared we're
left with an X so plus X and if we take
out a 5x of negative 30x we're left with
a negative 6 is equal to zero and now we
have 5x times this second-degree the
second-degree expression and to factor
that let's see what two numbers add up
to one you could view this as a One X
here and their product is equal to
negative six and let's see positive 3
and negative 2 would do the trick so I
can rewrite this as 5x times so X plus 3
X plus 3 times X minus 2 and if what I
just did looks unfamiliar I encourage
you to review factoring quadratics on
Khan Academy and that is all going to be
equal to zero and so if I try to figure
out what X values are going to make this
whole expression zero it could be the x
values or the x value that makes 5x
equals zero because if 5x is zero zero
times anything else is going to be zero
so what makes five X equal zero well if
we divide 5 if you divide both sides by
five you're going to get X is equal to
zero and it is the case if x equals zero
this becomes zero and then doesn't
matter what these are zero times
anything is zero the other possible
x-value that would make everything zero
is the x value that makes x plus three
equal to zero subtract three from both
sides you get X is equal to negative
three and then the other x value is the
x value that makes X minus two equal to
zero add two to both sides that's going
to be x equals two so there you have it
we have identified the three X values
that make our polynomial equal to zero
and those are going to be the zeros and
the x-intercepts so we have one at x
equals zero we have one at x equals
negative three we have one at x equals
at x equals two and the reason why it's
we're done now with this exercise if
you're doing some kind of kind of you
were just clicked into these three
places but the reason why folks find
this to be useful is it helps us start
to think about what the graph could be
because the graph has to intersect the
x-axis at these points so the graph
might look something like that it might
look something like that
and to figure out what it actually does
look like we'd probably want to try out
a few more x-values in between these
x-intercepts to get the general sense of
the graph